welcome everybody to the final video in
the little mini series that i'm doing on
various levels of puzzles so so far
we've done intermediate level puzzles
advanced puzzles and in the last video i
tried my hand it's a master level
puzzles but all throughout i've been
getting a lot of requests from people on
my stream and in the comments
uh to do a series of studies catered
toward beginners beginner level studies
and really talk about where to even
start if you're new to chess i i think a
lot of people who are new to chess
tend to get overwhelmed when they're
first solving exercises and don't know
where to start and um i've listened and
i'd like to do a video where i solve a
series of beginner level exercises and
obviously i'll walk through the
solutions as usual and i'll offer some
broad level tips so if you're new to
chess if you've only just learned the
rules and you're just starting to solve
exercises then this video is for you and
if you're more advanced then you
absolutely can still listen and
hopefully extract uh beneficial lessons
from this video as well so i've set the
range to be 200 to a thousand uh roughly
speaking you know the beginner range
we're going to get some varying
difficulty
but hopefully we'll get some good
exercises let's jump in
okay
so um first exercise we have a middle
game and
whenever i solve exercises there is a
sort of sequence of things that i tend
to do the first thing i almost always
tend to do is count the material so you
look at the position and in order to get
your bearings
you need to figure out if either side is
up
you know a certain amount of material
what does that tell you well if you've
counted up the material and you figure
out that you are down a queen that tells
you a lot about the the solving
condition of the of the exercise because
the condition of success cannot be to
win back a minor piece right you're
still going to be down a queen for a
minor piece
you almost know for certain that it has
to be something like checkmate if
material is equal
then for example winning a rook or
winning a piece can absolutely be
the solution because that's a very hefty
amount of material right so if we count
the material here
both sides have four minor pieces we
have our rooks and our queens and in
terms of the pawn count black is up one
pawn which is really not a big deal you
can kind of ignore differences like that
um in these types of puzzles that
doesn't really change anything unless
it's an end game
and the second thing that i try to do
is kind of get a broad understanding of
what's going on
you check the respective king safeties
uh you look at whether the center is
open or closed and you look immediately
for vulnerabilities in uh in black's
position your opponent's position
what do i see here i kind of see that
black's king is still in the center
that's a pretty big red flag because
we're castled and black is not the other
big red flag is that black's king side
is essentially undeveloped black hasn't
gotten the bishop out the rooks are
still on their initial squares whereas
white is castled and look at how all of
white's pieces are kind of amassed in
the center so that kind of tells me that
something is going on in the center now
what specifically well what else do i
see
the one of the first things i look for
in almost any position is also the
placement of my opponent's queen the
queen is obviously a magnet for all
sorts of tactics attacking the queen is
a big deal because you're essentially
forced to respond to that and so
combining the observation about black's
king being unsafe the sensor being open
and black's queen being right up in the
center and quite vulnerable you can
start looking for ways to attack black's
queen
okay so maybe you see the move bishop f4
but that square is unprotected so the
queen will just capture the bishop well
can we do anything with this knight we
absolutely can we can go knight to b5
attacking the queen
now is that a good thing is that does
that help well let's try to calculate
well what's going to happen after knight
b5 the queen's going to move where can
the queen move it can't go here
it can't go there
can't go to e5 can't go to f4 why am i
highlighting those squares in particular
because those are the only squares from
where the queen continues to defend the
c7 pawn it turns out that after an ip5
the queen has to move away from c7 then
we capture the pawn on c7 and why is
that a big deal well you're probably
familiar with the concept of a fork that
knight once it lands on c7 delivers a
fork to the rook and the to the rook and
the king and we win at the very least a
rook knight p5 okay queen before
we take
and um
we take the rook and the problem is
solved okay
all right next exercise
okay so here the material count is
pretty interesting
white has four pawns black is three
white has two rooks and black as a queen
and that is approximately equivalent
that is a material imbalance but it's
kind of like a 50 50 situation really
depends on the position
now let's understand the king's safety
both kings are very clearly wide open
right black's king is confined to the
side of the board it's cut off by the
rook so one thing that you can
immediately spot is that white threatens
to swing the other rook over to a8 with
a ladder mate right the one rook is
cutting off the king the other rook is
doing the checking what does that tell
us that kind of tells us that
we have to start looking for checks we
have to make a forcing move because if
we don't
um because you're solving an exercise
and this is not really cheating
but you've got to understand that
in in order to solve the exercise you're
going to have to win so just very
passively defending against the threat
is rarely going to do the job so a move
like queen c6 right which would defend
the a8 square it would defend against
the immediate mate threat but it doesn't
do anything it doesn't actually
further the cause
of trying to win the game so that's why
i immediately start looking for checks
the only piece that can deliver a check
is the queen okay queen c2 looks
tempting but there's a rook on b2 that's
guarding that square the queen also
moves diagonally so we can swing all the
way back to g1 and wait a second you
might notice that the white king is
unable to escape to c2 because there's a
pawn controlling that square and there
is a rook that the king that is blocking
the king from going out to b2 so queen
g1 is simply made in one right maybe you
saw that immediately but i was trying to
spell that out uh so that if you didn't
see it immediately hopefully i explained
the way that you can kind of stumble
onto this this type of move
okay
the next position here material is equal
both sides have a pair of rooks a queen
and a bishop and the pawn count is equal
so looking at the position broadly what
do i see immediately well i see that the
d file is open and there's a lot of
pieces there whenever there is a lot of
rooks on a file you kind of know for a
fact that stuff is going to go down on
that file and in particular what square
seems to be the center of the tension
well it's the d4 square right because
black is a rook there white is attacking
that square two times and black is
defending it two times as well so if a
square or a piece is defended the same
number of times that it's attacked then
taking that piece at the very best will
result in a mass trade so for example if
you take on d4
then the queen takes on d4 you trade
queens
and then black takes with the rook and
we haven't really accomplished anything
but
when there is a large number of pieces
that is defending another piece that
raises the possibility of an
interference tactic and an interference
tactic is when you literally put a piece
between two of your opponent's pieces
with the aim of severing their
coordination
and preferably the piece that you put in
between the two pieces could also be
threatening
uh one of the pieces so that way you're
essentially overwhelming your opponent's
defenses now that was maybe a little bit
confusing but try to apply that here
can you put something between the two
rooks you could play bishop d5 right and
that would be a pretty smart move
because if black captures the bishop
then we can capture black stroke
but what's the problem with bishop d5
pause the video try to figure that out
so the point is that black can take
white's rook after bishop d5 bishop d5
itself does not create enough of a
threat so black can take the rook
we have to take back and then black
simply takes the bishop of the pawn
but what about black's queen the queen
is not a great defender because it's
very easy to attack
there's not a lot of distance between
the queen and the rook but if you look
carefully you will see that you can push
that pawn out to e5 we can play pawn e5
that attacks the queens that's the main
difference between bishop d5 and e5 e5
carries a threat so if black takes the
rook on d1
we don't have to recapture we simply
take black's queen with check even if it
wasn't checked by the way that would
still be perfectly good enough
okay so after e5 what happens if the
queen just drops back
well then the queen no longer defends
the d4 rook and it's got two attackers
and one defender we win the rook
a black has one more attempt after e5
and that is queen f4 which they play
but now you have to see the bigger
picture here which is that while taking
on d4 no longer makes sense because the
queen still defends the rook this rook
is overloaded
first of all it's standing behind white
stroke on d1 and the rook on d8 which is
undefended
and it's also attacking or defending the
queen so what we simply need to do is
take the queen
the rook takes the queen and now we
slide on over and take the rook on d8
and one other important thing to notice
is that once we go e5 and the queen
moves that rook on d8 essentially is
undefended if we could get the stroke
off of d4 we would be able to take
black's other rook
okay so this is a classic interference
tactic and the way to spot it is to
identify pressure points in the position
which squares are the ones where there's
a lot going on and those are the squares
that you can try to gear your tactics
around if that makes sense okay
next problem
all right so so here again material
seems to be equal
night night bishop bishop to rooks and
queen
king safety
well it doesn't seem to indicate too
much i would say black's king is a
little bit more vulnerable because black
doesn't have a pawn on the g file but on
the flip side black's rook is x-raying
white's king so black might be
threatening to fianchetto the bishop
attack the queen and if the queen moves
that g2 pawn might fall
so that tells me we have to do something
pretty urgently
all right so what else do i notice is
the center open or closed well the
center is wide open there are no barely
any pawns in the center and that means
that there is likely to be contact
between pieces anytime there is contact
between two heavy pieces such as a queen
and a rook or a queen and another queen
or a rook
and a bishop you have to examine that
contact and see if you can't revolve
your tactic around it so i'm seeing that
the queen is hitting the rook on a8 and
if you've been watching my stream or my
other videos you might be familiar with
the terminology i've developed of type 1
and type 2 undefended pieces let me
recap that for those of you who are new
to my channel a type 1 undefended piece
is a piece that is not protected by any
other pieces
a black other than the queen and i
consider the queen to always be
undefended all right because even if you
defend a queen with a bishop and a rook
and a pawn and the queen is attacked by
a knight because the queen is the most
vulnerable valuable piece it still has
to move right
okay so the queen is always undefended a
type one undefended piece is the knight
on d4 it's not protected by any other
pieces those are the most vulnerable
pieces people are aware of that what
people often forget to check are type 2
undefended pieces and that is a piece
which is only protected by one other
piece and not a pawn
okay the rook on b1 is a type two
undefended piece the rook on a8 is a
type two undefended piece because it's
only protected by the knight and the
moment that i tell you that you should
immediately spot the solution because
you can see that your two rooks are
aimed at black's knight you can simply
take that knight and remove the defender
of the a8 rook after black takes the
rook and we take black stroke we are up
a night because we took a knight at the
start and black didn't boom boom the
most important thing here is to identify
type 2 undefended pieces because
oftentimes a tactic like this exists you
either take the piece or if we had a
pawn on a4 we could play a move like a5
chasing the knight away
and then black will have to choose
between giving up the knight and giving
up the rook
all right next position
okay so here black is down a piece
because white has a knight and black
doesn't
but what else do i notice don't get
overwhelmed when there's a lot going on
just try to sort of what you can do is
you can break up the i don't love doing
this but one thing you can do is if
you're a little bit overwhelmed is to
break the position up into its three
component sides right the queen side the
center
and uh the king side so let me see if i
can
draw them in different colors
very good so these are the three parts
of the board
and in general i always tell my students
to look at the whole board try not to
overly disattach each side of the board
because you can forget that one piece on
the king side can be aiming at something
on the queen side but it can be a
helpful way to make observations so
what's going on on the green part of the
board
well not much right there's a couple of
pawns there
white is attacking our pawn on c6 but
clearly that's not the most important
thing
what's going on on the two center files
well here i see something pretty
important
i'm seeing that the black rook is
x-raying white's bishop in fact it's
pinning white's bishop my apologies that
means that the bishop cannot move
without losing the queen
okay what do i see on the king side
well i see another x-ray type situation
look at this pawn on g2 does black just
have checkmate in one
well no if you look carefully you'll see
that white's queen defends g2
but white's queen also defends the
bishop and the bishop is a type 2
undefended piece to use our new
terminology it's only defended by the
queen so hypothetically if we could
distract the queen from the second rank
well then we would have checkmate and we
have just the way to do that we take on
d3 okay queen takes c3 is not the best
move clearly but that's the move that
they play
what should i do here white should move
the queen aside but then black is black
has recovered the extra piece and has an
overwhelming attack so for ease of
solving they take the rook and we take
on g2 this is a classic overloading
situation okay next position
aha this is very instructive
now count the material patiently
material is equal and you should notice
something very interesting here which is
that both queens are under fire white is
attacking black screen black is
attacking white's queen and that is a
situation in which you can essentially
follow a formula to find the right
tactic if it exists
the first type of move that you should
look for is whether you can move your
queen away with check now think about
why i'm recommending that because if you
move your queen away with check
presumably your opponent has to respond
to that check moving the king for
example but then you can take your
opponent's queen so if the white queen
could land on e6 here and check the
black king we would be
we would be in great shape the king
would have to move and we would win the
queen
unfortunately that's not possible here
we don't seem to have any
straightforward checks so the second
type of move that you should look for is
what's called a desperado sacrifice the
word desperado and julie just means
uh if you decide if you've decided that
you're already losing one of your pieces
you you don't just want to give away
that piece for nothing you want to give
away that piece for whatever you can get
for it right you essentially go to the
pawn shop no pawn intended
and you give away your piece for
whatever you can get for it so here's
the logic
if we have determined to take black's
queen wouldn't it be nice if we can
give away our queen for a piece even for
a pawn if nothing else presents itself
okay so should we take black's pawn on
f5
well no cause that move's not a check
and remember our rook on d1 is the type
two undefended p so black would simply
take it but what else can we get for the
queen look around can we take anything
well yes we can we can take the bishop
on g7 and that's also a check and after
king takes queen we take black's queen
and we are up a bishop we will have a
bishop and we've taken black's bishop
right you take on g7 you take on d2
sometimes both types of moves will exist
you'll have a check and you'll have a
desperado sacrifice what you have to be
very careful about is if the desperado
does not come with check if the
desperado is not a check your opponent
can counter desperado and for example
can take something even more if this
move was not a check black would have
been able to take the rook so it's very
very important that it is a check
okay next position well this is a made
in one
white is for what it's worth white is
down a lot of material but one thing
that you have to notice in many types of
positions is a battery that is when a
bishop and a queen are lined up on one
diagonal or a rook and a queen are lined
up on one file that is also a battery
and batteries allow you to infiltrate
your opponent's territory in this case
we spot the battery immediately where
are they aiming they're aiming at h7 can
we take that pawn well is anything else
defending it other than the king
looking around nope there's no knight on
f6 there's no rook on h6 we can just
take it and that is just checkmate right
that's just made in one
all right
um
maybe we'll do a couple more so white to
play in this position
all right so material seems to be equal
oh black is up upon
let's compare king's safety so our king
seems to be pretty safe black's king is
right in the center it seems to be
pretty wide open
now when you have identified your
opponent's king as weak
all right you have to understand
immediately well what tools do you have
at your disposal to attack your
opponent's king and there's a couple of
tools that you can specifically look for
the first is you have to look at your
rooks and see whether they're located on
open files a rook on an open file is a
very dangerous thing and an open file
can be the avenue through which you
infiltrate and actually exploit the
weakness of your opponent's king so this
shork on a1 is on a closed file but the
rook on b1 is on an open file right the
b file literally has nothing on it
all right so what do we do with this
open file well you can move the rook
to a place on that file and start the
attack against black skin so what move
comes to mind well what about rook b7
attacking the queen
well that's not a good idea because then
the queen's just going to take the rook
right
and following the common advice of
checks captures threats
if you follow that advice you would
start by looking at rook b8 check
now
i want you to understand if you're new
to chess that a check in and of itself
doesn't mean that it's if it's a check
it doesn't mean it's automatically a
good move a move is not good because
it's a check but checks can often be a
very
useful way of forcing the king onto
undesirable spots so after rook ba check
what options are available to black well
first of all you have to check whether
the check can be blocked
it can be blocked by the rook on d8 but
because white has the queen on h4 which
you noticed of course
the queen could take that row
and that doesn't help so after rook b8
black has to move the king where can he
move it he can move it to d7 or f7 but
not to e7 because the queen is
controlling that square
now try to visualize in your head how
the position changes after the king
moves let's say to f7 rook b8 king f7
what you have to look for
is alignment of heavy pieces if the king
and the queen are aligned and i said
that in a previous video if they are
aligned on the same rank on the same
file on the same diagonal it doesn't
matter same with the king and rook you
have to look for skewers checking the
king the king has to move and then you
win the queen and the skewer exists rook
b7 check now you can put the rook on the
seventh rank the king has to move and
then we win the queen
so
what i want you to notice is that the
result of this attack is not a checkmate
it's actually just a material win and
you'll often see that
i think as a beginner as a new player
you might be tempted to think that every
attack should end in checkmate but
that's not true when you are attacking
your opponent's king when you're
bringing your pieces into the game you
should always look for ways
to exploit the weakness of your
opponent's king but not by giving
checkmate but rather by doing something
like we do here
which is let's say to win and skewer and
win a queen right b7 rock takes g7 the
game is over
okay i think we have time for two more
and interesting position here
one second here
okay
so
again we have a lot going on but let's
not get overwhelmed
material is equal six pawns six pawns
opposite colored bishops for what it's
worth now where is the center of gravity
in this position well it seems to be the
e-file how do i know that so quickly
one piece of advice that i often share
even with higher-rated players
is to pay particular situations to
positions where there is only one open
file because if there is only one open
file and there there's bound to be a lot
of traffic on that file control of that
file is going to be very important so
i'm immediately looking at the e-file
there's a lot going on here
and i'm also looking at the alignment
between my bishop and black's queen that
is an x-ray who holds the power in that
x-ray well it's white we had a puzzle
like this in the previous video or the
video before that because what we can do
is something called a discovered attack
a discovered attack is when you have an
alignment between let's say a bishop and
your opponent's queen
and you have a piece in the middle that
piece in the middle can be moved out of
the way and that's where the discovery
comes from essentially opening up an
attack against that piece right so we
can move the rook and then black's queen
is going to be under fire where can we
move it well we don't just want to move
the rook anywhere right if we move the
rook let's say back to e3
well is that a good move no it's not
right because the queen's just going to
take the bishop so the move that we make
with the rook preferably either has to
be a check or it has to pose some
independent threat which your opponent
has to respond to
do we have a check well we do we can
take black strike that's why we've got
that open file
but if you look carefully you'll see
that it's not the end of the story
because the line goes on
if we take black stroke on e8 black
takes with his rook
well what's going on then then we have
the same situation we had two exercises
ago where both queens are hanging so
rook takes c8 rook takes c8 and if we
take black's queen black takes our queen
and material is equal
okay so let's remember what we have to
look for in situations where both queens
are hanging first of all we have to look
for checks second of all we have to look
for desperado captures but once again we
have a move that serves both of those we
can take black stroke with our queen and
when black takes with his bishop we take
black's queen and we're going to be up a
full rook
so rook takes c8 and this move should
come very logically to you if you sort
of paid careful attention to how i
explored that puzzle with both queens
hanging we take the rook then we take
black's queen
boom boom
and let's do one final exercise and this
one's an end game exercise
now we have a pawn end game where both
sides have two pawns the most important
thing and i'll definitely do videos sort
of more specifically geared toward end
games but for now what i'll say as a
shorthand is that king activity is the
most important thing in pawn end games
and what does king activity mean exactly
well it means generally one short way of
understanding it is how close your your
king is to your opponent's pawns because
ultimately you're not going to win this
end game unless you
win at least one of white's pawns right
then it's just going to be a draw if you
don't do that
what devices do you have of winning
white spawns you only can do that with a
king it's very hard to win a pawn with
another pawn
so black's king should be aiming at
white's pawns there's only one pathway
and that is to play king before and the
reason this is winning for black is
because white's king is simply too far
away from his own pawns we stick the
king on a3
we take the pawn and the problem is
solved this still needs to be won um and
you know analyzing this endgame is a
little bit outside the scope of this
video once again i'm planning to make a
lot of end game videos as well but um
this is winning suffice it to say we're
up upon and the win is pretty
straightforward here and
that was 10 exercises so
obviously uh if you if you're an
experienced player this should have been
very basic but if you're new to chess i
hope that you benefited from some of
these pieces of advice a couple of you
know points to summarize
first thing is remember to count the
material and always start by trying to
get a bird's eye view of what's going on
where is the tension happening are there
open files compare the safety of the
kings
and when you feel like you figured out
almost try to make a mental heat map of
the position and
also look for things like alignment is
your piece is your bishop staring at
your opponent's queen through the lens
of another piece
uh is there only one open file and a
bunch of rooks on it then you start
looking for background combinations are
both queens hanging you start looking
for desperado combinations so
essentially you build this mental
library of what to look for given
certain mental cues and eventually all
of that's going to go into your muscle
memory you won't actually need to remind
yourself to check these things your
brain will automatically do it that's a
very exciting progression if you keep
solving exercises you keep figuring out
why you went wrong where you went wrong
and how you could have gotten the
problem right i guarantee you you're
going to improve and you're going to
reach that point of automatization so i
hope you enjoyed the video and i hope
you enjoyed the puzzle solving series
i'll see you very soon in the next video
thank you very much for listening see
you soon